vous vous sentez comment en ce moment
[Musique]
je me sens un peu
comme anesthésié
[Musique]
et si on allait boire un verre dans mon
bureau
quoi ça dérange qui ta femme pour
commencer bonjour à tous Voici Stéphane
qui va remplacer très bas bonjour
cet endroit est fait pour ceux qui ont
besoin de s'évader pour ceux qui ne leur
place nulle part ailleurs
c'était magnifique autrefois ça l'est
toujours
[Musique]
tu viens d'où toi
ça arrive souvent ouais c'est comme ça
partout non
personne ne va vous donner la vie vous
voulez voiler de faire soigner parce que
tu as un gros problème tu sais
c'est à vous d'aller la chercher
[Musique]
ce rayon de lumière
c'est une évasion
[Musique]